se han descubierto los restos de 215
niños enterrados en los terrenos de una
antigua Escuela en British Columbia
Canadá se trata de uno de los mayores
internados para niños indígenas del país
gestionado por la iglesia católica desde
finales del siglo 19 los restos fueron
encontrados por los especialistas
utilizando un Geo radar el Primer
Ministro canadiense justito calificó el
descubrimiento de desgarrador twitteando
que era un doloroso recordatorio de un
capítulo oscuro y vergonzoso de la
historia del país algunos de los que
murieron en la escuela tenían solo tres
años no hay nada más doloroso en la vida
que perderá un hijo hoy se me rompe el
corazón al pensar en todos los padres
amorosos que nunca vieron a sus hijos
regresar a casa y a los que nunca se les
concedió la dignidad de saber lo que
pasó una investigación de seis años
sobre el sistema de escuelas
residenciales de Canadá concluyó en 2015
que más de 4.000 niños indígenas
murieron mientras asistían a las
instalaciones separados por la fuerza de
sus familias
fueron sometidos abusos físicos
violaciones y desnutrición otros fueron
utilizados como sujetos de experimentos
científicos la última de las escuelas
cerró en 1996 más de una década después
el gobierno canadiense emitió una
disculpa formal justito aceptó lo que
les ocurrió a muchos de los 150.000
niños que formaron parte del sistema que
constituye un genocidio cultural el
colegio Residencial indígena de camplups
cerró en 1978 y ahora es un museo y
Centro Cultural los grupos de la
comunidad indígena afirman que están
colaborando con el forense local Y
esperan tener las conclusiones
preliminares A mediados del mes que
viene